I've been trying to keep a hatred mail
related to the election because we only
have I guess it's one two there's three
no there's only two Wednesday's left uh
before the election so let's first
remind you what hatred mail is it's like
email for words from your racist grandma
on steroids
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom so this is pretty
topical this relates to the election
this relates to the sexual assault
allegations involving Donald Trump and
this is clearly someone who is very very
upset with a lot of the stories that are
that 17 stories now about alleged sexual
assault by Donald Trump let's take a
listen to what this very nuanced
analysis was from this caller
hey forty years ago David Pakman touched
my peepee and I am outraged I'm going to
the authorities and filing charges you
better watch out David I know what you
did and soon everybody's going to know
when you did I was sitting in a cafe and
I noticed a hand slipped up my pants and
grabbed me by the Gentiles
I turn around it's no other than grab
them by the Pakman
David Pakman grabbed my wig 20 years ago
listen and believe right I mean please
this is uh this is pretty odd uh so I
guess I mean I'm trying to understand
what this person is saying I guess the
argument is if there's an allegation
that someone was sexually assaulted and
chronologically it happened some time
ago then that the allegation is by its
nature not credible that that ice I
think is what this person is sort of
saying uh and it's also funny when they
you know that I don't know if this is
you know have these these emails the
grammar and spelling is often not great
so when they said I guess satirically
that once I grabbed them by the Gentiles
I think what they meant was the genitals
but it's funny grabbing someone by the
Gentiles when I'm Jewish so this is it's
clearly somebody who is completely
deranged and and really struggles with
writing and and how to communicate
effectively with programs but there is
something funny about that uh
that I I accusing me of at one point
grabbing somebody by the Gentiles listen
that we know all about why there are
often delays in time between when uh
there is an alleged incident of sexual
assault and when we hear about it right
I mean it you you really have to be
living under a rock at this point uh to
suggest that hey if you don't
immediately while it's happening or
within five minutes report an incident
to everybody you know then that that
sets up it indicates some lack of
credibility if you believe that I don't
think I'm going to be able to convince
you otherwise but my sense is that clear
thinking individuals sort of get that
that is a really bogus way to dismiss
allegations of sexual assault
and by the way Donald Trump
doing a great job of dismissing the
allegations when when he says in one
case that based on the woman's physical
appearance it's just not likely that
it's somebody that he would physically
assault so sexually assault not doing a
great job and uh that that apparently
convincing this caller Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home Tryon to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com slash TDP s I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses hi which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com slash TDP s it costs nothing